in recent weeks the Venezuelan embassy
in Washington DC has become an outpost
of the country's political crisis
activists supporting venezuela's
President Nicolas Maduro have been
staging a sit-in they're trying to stop
diplomats who support the opposition
leader one Guido from taking over the
building the US and the Organization of
American States recognize Guido as
Venezuela's president for the activists
say the u.s. is help the US government
is helping engineer a coup in Venezuela
GWS Helena Humphries sent us this report
from the embassy Venezuela's power
struggle is playing out here the
country's US Embassy in Washington DC
for two weeks now American supporters of
Venezuela's embattled Nicolas Maduro
have occupied the building day and night
they want to stop representatives of
opposition leader and self declared
interim president Juan Guido from
setting up shop the leftist group calls
itself the embassy protection collective
one of its leaders shows us inside my
flowers doesn't blame Venezuela's
leaders for the country's economic and
humanitarian crisis so much as her own
if the United States actually cared
about the economic situation in
Venezuela we would stop the economic
coercive measures that were using you
know the preventing them from having
access to their gold in the bank of
London or being able to use petrol
dollars you know we would stop you know
we would let them have the assets that
they have here in the United States that
the United States is holding on to we
would stop pressuring other countries
who try to you know provide goods to
them other activists say they're
concerned about the prospect of US
military intervention Americans have a
special duty to the people around the
world to stand up and oppose that kind
of aggression which is carried out in
our name but without our approval they
accused the u.s. of being part of what
they see as an overthrow of power I know
so much about the various coos in which
the United States has either been
complicit or the instigator and I think
this is a rare opportunity we have
to interfere ahead of time but time is
running out for the activists the US
government says the protesters are
breaking the law and will have to leave
he forced embassies like the one behind
me and now becoming flashpoints in an
international tug of war between two men
who are both claiming to be president of
one country nearly 60 nations have
joined the Trump administration in
backing one Guido
but this embassy in Washington remains a
rare outpost of support for Maduro